with a global public cloud computing
market topping 250 billion dollars in
2019 and more than 80% of all
organizations projected to migrate to
the cloud by 2025 cloud computing is a
massively growing business consequently
professionals with cloud architecture
expertise and the ability to design
build and migrate applications are in
massively high demand with Udacity snoo
AWS cloud architect nano degree program
students learn to plan design and
implement secure cloud infrastructure an
AWS s scale AWS is the world's largest
systems business and AWS cloud
architects earn salaries starting at a
hundred and twenty seven thousand
dollars a year annually students in this
nano degree program will begin by
designing and building high availability
infrastructure and move on to building
scalable secure and cost optimized
architecture with real-world hands-on
projects students learn to plan design
provision migrate and monitor
infrastructure in AWS for up to a
million users using industry standard
and open source tools after graduating
students will be well placed to take a
critical role in an organization's cloud
computing strategy as an AWS cloud
architect enrolling Udacity AWS cloud
architect nano degree program today